citizens of the reject Nation it is John
here today to check out the scream 6
trailer but before we do that I got a
very special guest some of you guys
might be familiar with a little bit and
that is my good friend Greg Alba how you
doing buddy what's going on there I'm
happy to finally join you guys I'm uh
Skyping in today from Colorado I'm here
normally in a situation like this I'd
just be like John you're on your own but
it's screamed and even though it's only
a minute long I was like scream is my
favorite horror movie franchise I love
like this so much so I was like you know
what no I'm gonna I don't know about
here Joe's gonna be joined to be in
Colorado tomorrow but uh I'm not here to
get married so you know very sleep
deprived but it screamed so let's do
this we gotta do this and I just love
this franchise too much yes sir so leave
a like for for marriage and for uh the
scream franchise
subscribe hit that Bell and all that
stuff let's just let's jump into the
trailer
[Applause]
oh that's a cool logo yeah
working it in with the six
City
David Bowie really is like got this
Halloween night
Joker scream
yo it's Adrian Chase it's pug
oh that is scary
oh
Mindy's nice gag they wouldn't they
wouldn't they would have just revealed
Mindy's dead right
no no no no no that's got to be a fake
out come on
yeah they can't do that to us
these train motifs John I give you
permission to give this video keep it
uncut it's just because I know it's
going to take me forever to send you my
footage
yes
yes well I mean so in that Spirit what
do you what are your thoughts are you an
inspired scream fan right now
uh I really thought it was a good one
minute tease of them doing their own
thing you know like I I like we've
talked about it I like scream five
um I don't love it quite to the extent
that a lot of people really loved it
even though I enjoy my experience with
it I know I won't go into like a whole
deep dive review of what the movie the
experience of the movies
I'm not going to redo that but I I do
feel like this time around it looks like
they're really going to be doing their
own thing and I'm excited for that you
know it's it's just interesting because
in Scream five they do have a a line in
there where they're talking about what
the stab franchise evolved into
and how they really try doing their own
thing and they did it without having
your your the main character the Legacy
character returning I forget exactly
what the line was but I remember that
really stood out to me because the one I
rewatched it it was I was aware enough
Campbell wasn't coming back for this one
so even though that movie was going out
of its way to be like it doesn't work
when you do that now they're really
giving themselves The Challenge to to do
that and I it's a it's it's going to be
interesting to take them out of um
my God you know I know so much about
this franchise but I always blank on the
name
of California oh it's foreign
a very interesting Concepts usually
where you go it's the next stage but I
think
you know like I love what these
directors did with uh I like the
intention of what they did with their
characters from The Scream five and also
I love what they do with ready or not
and I imagine that in the in the vein of
the way horror is now and the way how
Scream franchise works with characters
like Sydney Prescott watching them try
to move on from the trauma they suffered
in the last one but how that still
follows them around and then like that
Halloween night setting where all right
it's just another guy dressed up as
Ghostface but it's
it's it's uh oh no but what if this
guy's not just someone dressed up as
Ghostface for Halloween this is someone
doing this specifically to stalk us and
and why you know I think is going to be
a fun thing to unpack but I don't know I
feel like they're probably going to be
proceed with even more confidence this
time around where they can really do
their own thing and perhaps
I'm just so curious to see if this
becomes the thing that they talked about
in Scream five of where fans tend to
hate what franchises evolve into yeah
yeah that's that's the part of like are
they gonna be able to pull this off or
are they going to do what they said uh
what they said fans often get mad about
it you know so
yeah that's my my little stream of
Consciousness thoughts here absolutely
no I mean I it's yeah I'm hoping that
they can really take the gloves off and
go No Holds Barred and I know they've
said that they're gonna they've hinted
that that's gonna be a strongly gory
entry into the franchise which is one
thing but I feel like yeah it has to
come down to the cleverness of the take
I'm expecting a lot of Jason Takes
Manhattan jokes
um and just scrubbing through this
trailer I mean there are a lot of like
little horror movie Easter egg
characters especially in all the
costumes like there's a I mean a shout
out David Bowie but there's like a dead
eye there's a babadook there's a pinhead
uh cenobite from Hellraiser there's a
Jason on the train
um so you know like I'm I'm seeing a
bunch of you know contemporary horror
nods and things like that um but yeah
like the flip in the scenery I hope
brings a flipping sensibility and maybe
like I don't know there are two ghost
faces on the train which obviously
Harkens back to you know the many of the
previous his films often having at least
two people I wonder if this is gonna go
like even further like maybe into like a
cultish realm or something like that
just because I imagine in switching from
you know Coastal California town to you
know the hustle and bustle of New York
City life like they have to utilize like
the sheer volume of people and probably
the agoraphobia that comes with you know
like the Big Tall City and whatnot but
uh yeah I don't know like this is a cool
teaser because it just throws you yeah
right into the midst of the different
setting and how scary can be like you
know I feel like a lot of screen movies
have played on like the Halloween party
as being like this sort of crowd
scenario where you know uh uh uh someone
might you know fake you out or
ultimately be able to get the drop on
you as Ghostface and now you only have
that problem like times a million uh
with the flavor of the city but uh yeah
but yeah
um I'm I'm cautious mostly optimistic
and and I agree it's like I'm hoping
that with this entry
radio silence can really you know feel
that I think they said on the first
movie they had uh the the fifth movie
there first in the franchise that they
had a lot of reverence and they had a
lot of you know things that they needed
to uh be respectful about and so with
this one they wanted to yeah challenge
themselves to just go all out and do
their thing with it and uh and that
excites me because I think like yeah
scream five I agree like there's a lot
of stuff I do enjoy about it but I
didn't love it the same way everybody
else did and I feel like a lot of that
maybe has to do with how do you take
over for Wes Craven after Wes Craven has
shaped this franchise over four movies
and uh and now yeah I'm hoping that they
can deliver us something that's really
different and really exciting and and
that still has that meta commentary Edge
uh without yeah falling into being what
it is trying to comment on instead of
you know standing a level above that and
yeah like Mindy this has to be a fake
out like and I and I almost wonder if
this moment on the train is like
somebody they know playing a prank or
something like that just to get us riled
up
um but yeah all the medic commentary
part is
that I think that I think they're
immediately take it out of New York and
it literally the Supreme five sets up
with certain key lines of dialogue from
where they say the stab franchise
evolved into it sets it up to do exactly
that kind of commentary of what happens
when you remove your main final girl
what happens when you like like weirdly
I think Neve Campbell not coming back
could be what if it's even though it's
like it pains me at the same time I'm
like yeah yeah well that's where your
comment some of your commentary can come
in
um with not having your final girl
return and just focusing on new
characters and um yeah I think the
brother's still alive too to Mindy uh
which kind of surprised me I thought he
was for sure dead but anyway yeah man
that was great we should uh gotta send
this footage to you but I'm glad uh I
love this franchise that's still my
favorite horror franchise so yeah oh
sure sure well that's good I'm glad
we're both excited then so yeah like
subscribe leave a comment about what you
thought of the trailer and uh we will
catch you guys soon much love
gotta go prep wedding
yeah go get go get married go go get out
of here
[Music]